REGINA: Thank you everyone for
joining us here in the room.
And virtually on
the live stream.
I'm super happy to welcome
Susan back to the Bay Area.
I thank her for sharing
her time with us.
She is professor of psychology
at Williams College, where
she's also the founder and
director of the Williams
Program in Teaching.
She's also the author of
"The Stories Children Tell,"
"Context Is Everything,"
"Real Kids," "Red Flags or Red
Herrings," and what's
available here today,
"The End of the Rainbow."
SUSAN ENGEL: One other
book. "The Hungry Mind."
REGINA: Oh, and
"The Hungry Mind."
See, there's so many books,
I can't keep track of them.
So, some context.
I met Susan at the Common Ground
series talk earlier this year.
And I left that talk uber
hopeful, inspired, and eager
to put much of what was
learned into practice.
And one of the great
things about working here
is when we meet people
outside of here,
then we have the opportunity to
make these talks happen here,
and then share the talks
with our Google family,
and then share it with
the world on YouTube.
So I also wanted to
share just personally
that as you were
speaking, it reminded me
of the conversations
that I have with my kids
at the end of the day.
And oftentimes when they're
very excited about something,
you see this spark
in their eyes,
like they're about to burst.
And they can't wait to share
what's happened in the day.
And I left your
talk, I felt like I
had tools to make that
happen more and more.
SUSAN ENGEL: Great.
REGINA: So welcome, Susan.
And thank you for sharing
more with us today.
So this is going to
be very much a Q&A.
And if folks have any questions,
we don't have a [INAUDIBLE],
but please share them here.
Or Ping a friend that you know
that is attending the talk,
and we will ask.
But I want to start off with
this picture that some of you
can see, and some of you
may not be able to see.
So I will describe it.
But it is two little
girls really in a moment,
they're sitting
outside and they are
looking at something intently.
And we start our
literary journey
as children really
drawn to picture books.
So I thought it would
be nice to start
our talk with this picture.
Fittingly, you brought
this picture to share.
Can you share more about
the story behind this?
SUSAN ENGEL: I'll tell you
the story of this picture.
So, the smaller blonde
girl holding the dandelion,
that's me when I
was about three.
And the story behind it is
that when I was very little,
I lived in a very small
village called Sagaponack,
on the eastern end
of Long Island.
And my stepdad was
a potato farmer.
And it was incredibly rural.
And I had enormous freedom.
Much more freedom
than children do now.
I basically rode
my little tricycle
around the village
all day by myself.
My mom might say,
watch for a car.
That was about it.
Then I went off and
I visited neighbors.
And I wandered around.
And inevitably I'd end
up stopping with my trike
by the edge of a potato
field, because that's
what surrounded us.
And I'd get off the
trike, and I'd kneel down.
I just loved the potato fields.
I loved the smell of dirt.
I liked the look of the plants.
And I'd kneel down and
I began to investigate
what was around me.
And usually I'd see something
called a potato bug.
So they're a terrible
problem for potato farmers,
but a delight for
little girls like me.
And they look a little
bit like ladybugs.
They have a hard
dome-shaped surface.
And they creep along.
And I'd watch.
I'd get closer and closer.
And then typically what
would happen is at some point
that I could never explain,
two translucent wings
would come out of their dome.
And they'd fly.
They'd fly from one
to leaf to another.
And just as inevitably as
they'd make that little flight,
I'd reach out and
I'd pick one up.
And I'd bring it close to me.
I'd put it in my mouth.
And I'd bite it.
And the thing about
that is, I wasn't mean.
I certainly wasn't hungry.
I just wanted to know
what was going on inside.
And the reason I tell that
story is because virtually
every child all over
the world starts life
with that kind of ravenous
appetite for knowledge,
for finding things out.
It's the engine that
drives learning.
So when you wonder about how
children under the age of five
can learn as much
as they do, they
learn more in those
first five years
than we ever learn
again in our life.
They learn to talk, they learn
to navigate the social world,
they learn an enormous
number of things.
Why?
Because they're curious
about everything.
They want to explain everything.
They want to
understand everything.
The question that
leads to is why
is this powerful, robust,
pervasive characteristic
of early childhood-- why does it
begin to wane as we get older?
Why does something that's
so sturdy and strong
you just almost can't tamp
it down in the two-year-old?
So a few of you probably
have had two-year-old,
and some of you
are going to have
a two-year-old in the audience.
And you will know that
you put a two-year-old
in the corner of a room,
and wait a few minutes,
and they'll make their
way around the whole room
investigating everything.
They're like a
one-person wrecking crew.
And that's because of this
enormous drive to find out.
So the question that I have
spent the last 12 years trying
to answer is, why it is that
such a sturdy characteristic
begins to wane, and
in many children,
virtually disappears by the
time they're in middle school.
And that's what
led me to the book
that Regina mentioned, "They
Hungry Mind-- The Origins
of Curiosity in Childhood."
I wanted to understand what
curiosity was, how it develops,
and why, as I said, something
so sturdy becomes so fragile.
REGINA: So what inspired
this latest book?
Because as you mentioned, you've
written all of these others.
And I'm thinking
there may be a story.
SUSAN ENGEL: There is.
There's a story for everything.
About 12 years ago, I co-founded
an experimental school
for children.
And that was about 18 years ago.
But about 12 years ago, I
was sitting with the faculty.
And we were talking about what
their goals were for the year.
So I was leading them
and guiding them.
And I said, what is
it you want to have
happen during the next year?
What do you think
these kids should
be able to do at the end of the
year that's different than what
they can do now?
And the teachers in
this school kept saying,
it's not how many
words they can spell.
It's not many math facts
they can solve in 30 minutes.
It's not how many
states in the country
they can locate on a
map on a piece of paper.
And what they were referring
to were standardized tests,
obviously.
It's none of those things.
That doesn't capture
what we're trying
to educate our students for.
And I kept saying, OK.
You don't like those things.
What is it you
want your children
to get out of this experience?
And they said-- each of
them had a different answer.
But all of the answers ended
up coalescing around the idea
that they wanted children
to be hungry for knowledge.
They wanted them to want to
find out about the world.
They wanted them
to want to learn.
And I left that
meeting thinking I
couldn't get it out of my
mind that what they wanted
was for children not
only to be curious,
to become more curious as a
function of their experience
in school.
And I thought, you know,
I went to a conference
actually then on
child development,
which I do all the time.
And I though, we
are a society that
measures what we value and
values what we measure.
And it's all very well
for teachers or parents
to embrace curiosity or pay
lip service to curiosity.
But if they're measuring
something altogether different,
like math facts or
spelling, that's
what they're going to
emphasize in the classroom.
And my original
idea was, I know.
I'll come up with a
measure of curiosity.
And all will be solved.
And schools will be wonderful.
Children will go on eating bugs
for the rest of their life.
Well, that was 12 years ago.
And easier said than done.
I realized I had to learn a lot
about how curiosity develops,
what it looks like in the
classroom, how it manifests
itself.
And that's what really led
me to 12 years of research
into that book.
REGINA: So the
title of your book--
why do you believe
it's important to teach
our kids that the
pursuit of happiness
is greater than the
pursuit of money?
SUSAN ENGEL: OK.
Good question.
So this is the other book.
I wrote two books last year.
I don't recommend that.
I was very tired at
the end of the year.
But the book Regina's
talking about,
"The End of the Rainbow,"
came from the fact
that all during that time that
I was looking at curiosity
and trying to understand it
and doing experiments about it,
I was thinking about this
question of how you measure it.
What would be a
good measure of it.
And somewhere along the
way, I thought you know,
I'm like those teachers.
I'm not sure standardized
tests capture
what we think is important.
And I actually then did
a very careful study
of all the existing
research, looking
at what standardized tests
predict about a child later on.
And it turns out they
predict almost nothing.
So they're a good
sorting system,
or good in the
sense that they are
useful to some people
in some settings.
They don't really
tell you anything
about what you might wish
your child or your student
or other people's children to
get out of school experience.
And I began, when I looked
into all those studies, what
occurred to me is that our
ideas about measurement,
about educational measurement,
are totally linked to our ideas
about success, which we've
come to define as financial.
So kids go to school.
They're going to
make more money.
And the terrible
effect of that is
that we've come to
think of schools
as a training ground for work.
And that's not what
schools should be.
So you started with the
story about your daughters
and how their eyes
light up when they're
excited about something.
Very few people
would say that what
they hope for most for their
child is that they're rich.
And if they do think
that, they should
read the research which shows
that actually having more money
doesn't lead to happiness.
You need enough money.
And going to school-- the
fact of going to school--
ensures that people are more
likely to have enough money,
to have a house, to have food.
So I'm not disparaging
the importance of that.
But that has nothing to do
with what goes on in school.
That has to do with
going to school.
When I began to think
about that I thought,
this is not what people
want for their children.
And it's not good for children
to have the school experience
shaped by a quest for money,
and more and more money,
or to have school
be shaped by a quest
to train people to
be good workers.
What people really want for
their children is to be happy.
And as I began to think about
that, I began to think, OK.
What would that look like?
What would a school look
like that was educating
for happiness, not money?
And I came up with
an answer of sorts.
And that's what
the book is about.
What a school would
look like, what children
would be doing if we thought
of something other than money
as the goal of education.
REGINA: So if we're
thinking about something
other than money, and if
we're putting curiosity first,
how could schools
encourage curiosity more
in the classroom?
SUSAN ENGEL: OK.
Can I give a two-part
answer to that?
REGINA: Yes.
SUSAN ENGEL: OK.
So in the book, "The
End of the Rainbow,"
one of the things I
talk about is curiosity,
because in fact, inquiry is
at the heart of a full life.
Wanting to know things and
knowing how to find things out
is essential.
It's not just essential
to be good at your job,
it's essential to having
a meaningful life.
And when people talk
about lifelong learning,
that's what they're
talking about.
So curiosity is
one of the things
I talk about in "The
End of the Rainbow."
So I'll answer
that part quickly.
What would a curious
classroom look like?
It would be a place
where children
have plenty of time and
encouragement to ask questions,
and then just as
importantly, to seek answers
to those questions.
And for some children,
that has to do with talk.
So one of the best ways
to express curiosity
is to ask questions.
In fact, some of
my research, we've
looked at the questions
kids ask in school.
And it turns out
that while children
at home, when they're
two and three--
get ready for
this-- ask anywhere
between 26 and 100
questions an hour
to their caregiver,
their mom, their dad.
By the time they get
to school, they're
more likely to ask about
two questions per hour.
When we looked in schools,
we saw an incredible absence
of question-asking on
the part of children.
So for many kids, a simple
thing is to make lots of time
for conversation.
Conversation is the single
most underrated tool
a classroom can have.
And children who are
privileged to have
come from educated, rich
family lives-- not money-rich,
intellectually
rich family lives--
what makes the difference
for them is lots of talk.
So schools, instead
of bypassing that,
should replicate it for kids
who aren't getting a lot of talk
at home.
But some kids aren't
question askers.
And so classrooms
need to have all kinds
of other opportunities
for inquiry.
And I bet there
are a lot of people
who work here at Google
who were tinkerers
when they were little.
Liked to take things apart.
Liked to peer at things.
Liked to try things out.
Test the waters.
Try something a little
dangerous and see what happens.
And classrooms
need to have that.
They need time.
Ask any researcher.
Ask people who work here to
learn to find new things out,
to make discoveries, you
need to get to dead ends.
You need to make mistakes.
You need to try it again.
I needed to eat so
many potato bugs
when I was little, to figure
out what was going on.
One wasn't enough.
So kids need time.
They need a chance
to pursue things
they're really interested in.
So we're not all interested
in the same thing.
And each kid needs to be able
to inquire about something
they really care about.
It's never going to be
that one topic or one set
of materials that's going
to work for all children.
And finally, they need
curious adults around them.
So in some of our
studies we've manipulated
how the adult is behaving.
And it turns out
that not only do
adults need to encourage
curiosity and ask questions
and answer questions, they
need to be curious themselves.
And our research shows
that when they are,
it has measurable impact on
children's own curiosity.
And that has all kinds of
interesting implications
for teacher
preparation, because I
don't think teachers
get enough chance
to pursue their own curiosity.
Then there's some
other things that I
talk about in "The
End of the Rainbow,"
other qualities that are key
to happiness besides curiosity.
It's important, but
it's not the only thing.
So I talk about collaboration.
I talk about thoughtfulness.
I talk about the
love of reading.
So there's a whole list.
And for each of those there
are-- and one other thing
I'll say that's key to that,
and related to curiosity,
engagement.
So I was thinking about this
as I was on my way over here
today.
We think of engagement
as a tool to get
kids to learn information or
learn very specific skills.
It is a tool.
But it's not just a tool.
It's the goal.
Because a person who is capable
of being deeply engaged in
things that are
meaningful is going
to be a well-educated grownup.
And they're gonna live
a much better life.
And yes, they'll probably
be better at their job.
But that's not the
main reason for that.
So one of the things that's key,
and very related to curiosity,
is giving children opportunities
to get deeply engaged
in something.
REGINA: Thinking about a
time-- and I'm using again
the data point of my
children, and as I
see them go through
the gradee-- they
have more time to
tinker and explore
in the preschool
years versus later.
And then I'm just predicting
that later on, they're
going to have even less time.
So how do we encourage this
with that limiting time
that they're going to be
facing year over year?
SUSAN ENGEL: We
should change that.
I mean, you can't do
the things that I'm
talking about within the
current school setup.
The idea that you can
do everything-- and I
hear this all the time.
I visit schools all
over the country.
Yes, we're going to have curious
children and children who
are deeply engaged, and
kids who work together.
That's a great example.
Kids who really help each other
and take care of each other.
And we're going to
get high test scores.
And they're gonna
learn three languages.
And they're gonna ace the
SATs, or whatever it is.
And actually,
that's not possible.
You pick something.
And you do it well.
Some of the things that are
currently valued in school,
like the ability to argue well
or to do well at your work,
I think would come with
the things I'm suggesting.
I don't think you'd have to give
up all of those aspirations.
But you'd have to give
up the idea that those
should shape the school day.
So you cannot learn 27 different
things about paper and pencil
mathematics, which children
currently have to learn--
God knows why-- and also give
children a chance to go deeply
into something, ask
good questions, tinker.
So it's a question of
shifting what's important.
REGINA: What do you think
about how we-- actually, you've
been answering this already.
But if you want to
add more to this,
like how we assess success
in our schools today.
SUSAN ENGEL: Right.
So, you know,
success, as I said,
I would argue has
come increasingly
to be defined by money
and sort of relayed power.
You know, I did a study
a few years ago with one
of my students at Williams.
We sent out a survey
to parents about what
they hoped for their children.
And the parents of
the younger children
said things like, I
want my child be happy.
I want them to find love.
Turns out that's
really important.
And I want my child
to have something
she or he loves to do.
When we asked parents
of older children, kids
who were like getting near
the end of high school,
fewer and fewer of
them answered that way.
They said-- it's
captured perfectly
by one person who answered
the survey with two words.
A lot of people gave
along paragraph about what
they wanted for their kids.
But this one parent
of a 15-year-old
had two-word answer.
Med school.
So as our children
get older, we get
more and more focused on certain
ideas about what success is.
And yet the research, not
just from psychologists,
but from economists as
well, shows pretty clearly
that in adult life-- those two
things don't sync up perfectly.
So having the best job,
or having the most money,
is not what will make your
life most meaningful, most
fulfilling, most joyous, even.
So I think our current
measures of success in school
are pretty
impoverished, actually.
And they take on a
life of their own.
They seem meaningful
because we treat them
as if they're meaningful.
But actually, the number a kid
gets on a paper and pencil test
doesn't have much to do with
what they're getting out
of the school experience.
And it has very little to
do with what their life will
be like when they're older.
REGINA: Can you talk about
any of the gender differences
that you've seen
in your research?
SUSAN ENGEL: You know, I haven't
seen many gender differences.
Although it would be very
interesting to find out.
There are gender differences
in terms of early language.
So girls tend to--
tend-- to talk more.
And maybe boys tend
in some research
to sort of be more interested
in tinkering or certain kinds
of object manipulation.
They are not different in terms
of their level of curiosity.
And that has to do simply with
giving kids an opportunity
to be curious about the thing
they want to be curious about.
But within that, there
are individual variations.
So that's one of the
interesting things.
Even as adults, I mean, I
bet if you did a survey here
at Google, you'd
find some people
are more curious than others.
There are important
individual differences
in levels of curiosity.
I don't think they go by gender.
But I don't really
understand completely
what they're related to.
There's not a perfect
correlation with intelligence
either.
Part of it has to do
what they experienced
when they were young.
So in my fantasy
school, curiosity
would be the goal of
the educational process,
not a sort of starting point.
But even so, at
the end of the day,
some people would be
more passionate seekers
of information than others.
I mean that's a good thing that
we're not all the same, so.
REGINA: So how do we balance
this curiosity with the things
that our kids need to know?
Like, there's always
going to be something
that oh, I want to spend
more time on subject X.
Because that's what
I'm passionate about.
SUSAN ENGEL: What do you
think kids need to know?
REGINA: It's going to be
a different answer per job
here, and per interest.
SUSAN ENGEL: I don't think
there are many things
that all kids need to know.
They need to be able to read.
I think they need to know
how to ask a question.
And they need to
know the difference
between a good question
and a weak question.
So one of the ideas that
I talk about in both books
is what it would take
to educate curiosity.
The same way all these things--
collaboration, engagement--
they're not just things that
you make a beautiful classroom
and then those things happen.
They require good
teachers guiding children
in skillful ways.
So I mean, I'm a researcher.
So I can spend
years-- I did spend
years trying to
think of the best way
to ask my questions
about curiosity.
And that's true for any of you.
You sometimes have to
spend time figuring out
what your question is.
Kids aren't given much
practice at refining,
revising, re-asking
their question.
Sometimes you ask the
question and a day, or a year,
or five years later,
you think, oh, I
have to shift that
question a little,
and I'll get a better answer.
So that's part of it.
They need to know then
how to go about finding
the answers they need.
Not all questions will lead
you towards the same path
to get answers.
Some questions are more
data-bound than others,
for instance.
And then finally,
kids need to learn
how to decide when their
question's been answered.
And one of the worst
mistakes we make in school
is to tell them
all the time when
they've answered the question.
How do we tell them?
By giving them a score.
Instead of asking them,
are you satisfied?
The beautiful thing
about curiosity
is, the more you know about
something, if you're actually
interested in it, the
more you want to know.
Because you become attuned
to ever deeper levels
of information and subtlety.
So to answer your
question-- I didn't
mean to put you on
the spot-- but what
kids need to know,
in my view it's
a very different
cluster of things
than we tend to think it is.
There are very few
bodies of knowledge
that all children must have
in order to be well-educated.
I play this game
with my students
at Williams, who take a
course with me on education.
At some point early
in the semester
I ask them to think
of somebody they
know who's really well-educated.
It could be anybody.
From their family, from their
town, from their summer job,
or at school.
And they describe the person.
And then I say, OK.
What is it about that
person that makes
them seem well-educated to you?
And I get all these
wonderful answers.
I get he's wise.
She's eager for knowledge.
She can relate to
many different people.
She's able to collect
information and connect it
in interesting ways.
Students say all
kinds of things.
I've been doing this
game for about-- I
don't know-- 18 years.
I've never had a student say,
he really knows polynomials.
Or she really can parse the
hell out of any sentence.
It turns out those aren't the
measures of a good education.
And yet, it's not that
knowledge is unimportant.
It's that people get
knowledge if they
have these other skills.
So you must know in
your job that the things
you need to know about are
related to the things you
must do or want to do.
And the question is, are you
good at getting that knowledge?
So when you say, what is
it all kids need to know?
I'm not sure there are
any bodies of knowledge
that all kids must know.
And by the way, in
our current system,
they don't all know it anyway.
So even setting it up that
way doesn't actually work.
REGINA: So on the current
setup, why do you think
we test for what we test for?
SUSAN ENGEL: Oh, boy oh boy.
I wish I knew the
answer to that question.
It's expedient.
And that's, to me,
the worst mistake.
So let me say that
when I started
talking about these
things in public settings,
everybody who agreed with me
about the problems of testing--
current system of
testing-- assumed that I
meant we shouldn't assess.
And I don't mean that at all.
We have to assess children.
And schools have to
be held accountable,
because we have to know if we're
doing a good job or a bad job.
I'm all for that.
And here's the great news.
We are good at measuring
a lot of these things.
Psychologists have been
measuring these things forever.
Probably you've
had speakers here
who've talked about things
like unconscious bias,
unconscious stereotyping.
Or the impulse to gamble.
Or what makes us fall
in love with people
we fall in love with.
Those are all based--
those findings--
on our ability to measure the
invisible or the ineffable.
So there are ways to measure
what kids are learning,
or what's going on
in the classroom
so that we can hold
schools accountable.
Why we use paper
and pencil tests?
One, they seem easy.
And they create an illusion of
hard data, which is a fallacy.
Anybody can make a
number out of anything.
It doesn't mean the
number means anything,
or tells you anything
about a person.
Honestly, somebody's going
to hate me for saying this,
but it's turned into
a huge business.
And it's taken on, like I said
before, a life of its own.
I mean, even in my hometown,
everybody says they hate tests,
but on the day that the
test scores come out,
everybody looks to see whether
their kids are in the district
with the high test scores.
And for that
minute, when they're
looking at the
newspaper, they've
forgotten that those
numbers don't necessarily
tell you anything about what
those students are getting out
of school.
AUDIENCE: For parents,
if I look at a test,
and I can tell hopefully-- say,
a math test, I know 2 plus 2
is 4.
But I hear, your son is not
curious enough or they're not
having enough fun
in class because
the subjective evaluation
of a professional-- I
can argue against that a lot
more and say, you're wrong.
My son is curious enough.
He's learning.
He's connecting the dots.
He's engaged.
And let's talk to the
principal, or I want
to talk to the superintendent.
I don't believe you.
Whereas a 96 on the
test, or a 40 on the test
is evidence that I
can't argue with, right.
So even if you
say we can measure
those things for a lay
person to have a confidence
level at that, it
might be easier for us
as a parent to understand
and for administration
to deal with.
SUSAN ENGEL: So I
think, if I understand
what you're asking about,
it's what-- you might all
disagree with me and think that
the current tests work well,
and the current school system
works well and I'm wrong.
So then there's not much
discussion about this.
But if you agree with
me, and the question
is, how do you help a
community of people-- teachers,
administrators, and parents--
to make this as firm
and convincing and reliable
as the number on the test.
Is that your question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SUSAN ENGEL: But I
think that's where I'm
suggesting something different.
So in the book, in
the last chapter,
I talk about very
tangible quantitative ways
to measure these things.
For instance, I'll give you
one very simple example.
Conversation, I think--
and I've told you this,
and research supports
this-- is key
to intellectual development.
And kids who get a
lot of conversation
tend to do better in all kinds
of ways, including learning
to read better, and all
kinds of other cognitive
tests than kids who are
deprived that kind of exchange.
And schools would do well to
promote more conversation.
Well, we could be
measuring the conversations
that go on in schools.
We could have video cameras
taking random samples.
That's a common
technique in research.
You go in and tape
record at times
that no one's aware you're
going to tape record.
But everybody knows that
will happen at some point.
And you take those
snippets of conversation.
And you simply count
how many conversations,
how long the conversations are,
how many turns individual kids
get to take.
These are all
well-established measures
from developmental research.
They've been around for years.
And they end with a number.
It's just that it's a
number that tells you
something more important
and probably more
valuable than some other
things we're currently
assigning the number to.
So I don't think it
would be adequate
for teachers, or
anybody, just to say,
in my gut this kid is
really thriving, or engaged,
or intellectual, or thoughtful.
I think we do have to measure
those things in a way that
ultimately can be represented
in a graph or a number.
Partly for the reason
that you're talking about.
Also, people fool themselves.
I had a teacher once say,
I don't need those tests.
I know in my gut
when a kid can read.
Well, I loved that
particular teacher.
But I didn't trust her.
We fool ourselves.
So we do need
objective measures.
We just need measures of the
things we actually value,
rather than something
altogether different.
So I hope that
answered your question.
AUDIENCE: I agree with this.
The test scores
on math and stuff.
But it's easier, especially
for less educated parents,
to potentially have a trust
in a math test than video--
not understanding that we're
going to monitor and capture
those things.
And do I have to
coach my kid to make
sure they're in front
of the video engaging
during those times, or something
like that versus, I know,
I trust that the
scoring on the test.
Even if I don't know
polynomials as a parent,
that the school graded those.
But the other things
feel more subjective.
And I can argue.
And for the school it's
easier to point to, no.
They failed the
test, rather than
the squishier things that are
really important versus just
math mechanics.
SUSAN ENGEL: Right.
I mean, the trouble
is, those tests
have been around a long time.
And everyone has
gotten used to the idea
that they're trustworthy.
And so that partly is
going to take time.
Let's say in my dream
world, a bunch of schools
said, let's get rid
of these measures.
Let's use these measures.
Let's educate for these goals.
It would take some time.
I'm guessing it wouldn't take
as much time as people think,
especially if your kids came
home interested and engaged
and happy, and you had
these measures that said--
and some of them by the way
aren't even as sort of fuzzy
sounding as that.
There are very interesting
ways to measure kids' ability
to ask good questions,
or to follow
a task from beginning
to end, and be
thoughtful about something.
Those would quickly take
on the kind of substance
that we now give over
to these other tests,
even though they don't merit.
It would take some time.
I had so many calls
from school principals
after a piece of that book
came out in the "Boston Globe."
I had so many teachers
and principals
calling me and
saying, what would it
take to actually
make this happen?
And the truth is
all it would take
is a group of people
deciding to do it.
I mean, nothing
magic about that.
REGINA: Do you see
any groups doing this?
Like, do you see any
experimental schools,
or whatever.
SUSAN ENGEL: Yeah.
Yeah so they're--
REGINA: How do you
see them doing it?
SUSAN ENGEL: Well, they're doing
it in really interesting ways.
And some of them-- the
saddest part for me,
to be totally candid is that
too many of the schools that
are brave enough to do this
kind of approach-- it's not just
the measurement,
it's the approach
and the measurement--
are private schools.
And the real key is to make
this accessible to all.
So there are some really
interesting public schools
dotted all over the
country that are
moving towards this approach.
But it's harder for some of
the reasons you just mentioned.
It's harder for them
to make the leap.
And that's what I would
like to see happening
in the next few years.
And actually, there's no
reason for them-- well,
the reason is worry.
But concretely speaking, there's
really nothing to stop them.
For instance, you could say, OK.
We know they have to take
the paper and pencil test,
but we're not gonna
worry about it.
Instead, we're going
to emphasize these ways
of learning in school.
And we're going to measure
them in these three
ways for the next five years.
And we'll see what happens.
They have very little to
lose doing that, actually.
But I guess it takes a certain
kind of bravery to start with.
So I'm hoping for that.
Fingers crossed.
REGINA: On the bravery
part, I'm uh-- can you
share some insight into how your
approach has panned out for you
personally with your family?
SUSAN ENGEL: Oh.
So I'm going to
tell my son's story.
This is funny.
So I started this-- I'll
take you back to curiosity.
I started this talking
to you about how
young children have
this voracious appetite
for all kinds of knowledge.
But the truth is,
schools aside, it's
inevitable that as kids
get a little older,
their curiosity kind
of narrows down.
And the reason is, when
you're very little--
so curiosity is
defined as the need
to resolve uncertainty or
explain the unexpected.
And that's sort of the
psychological definition
of curiosity.
So you can understand
why when you're
nine months old or two years
old, everything's unexpected.
Everything seems uncertain.
You want to know about
the juice and the bug
and the chair, and the door
opening, and the new face.
So you're curious
about everything.
As you get older, more
and more of everyday life
gets to be sort of
familiar to you.
So you begin to
narrow your curiosity
to things that hold great
interest for you, which
is why even in the best of
environments, by the time
your kid is five, they'll
be curious about some things
and not about others.
And the things
they're curious about,
they're very curious about.
They can't get enough of it.
So I have three sons.
They're grown now.
And we lived also in
a very rural area.
Not the one I grew up
in, but a different one.
And my kids spent a lot of
time outdoors and a lot of time
with animals and nature.
So one time I took my
four-year-old son, Sam,
to the Central Park
Zoo in New York City.
And we went into this space,
this beautiful exhibit,
the tropical exhibit.
And there were lizards and
there were gorgeous birds,
and it was steamy, and there
were all these cool-- probably
not as exotic to you--
but palm plants and stuff.
And there were these tortoises
sort of lumbering along
in the exhibit.
And most of the kids in that
room were amazed by everything.
I could see them.
Everything was a
surprise to them.
But not my son, because he
had been to a lot of zoos.
He'd spent a lot of time of
time with all kinds of animals.
He'd read a lot of
books about animals.
So almost everything
that they were doing,
he already was familiar with.
But one tortoise had lumbered
over and made its way,
trudged over, and climbed up on
the back of another tortoise,
and was letting out
these loud, weird noises.
Even my son had not see that.
And suddenly he piped up with
his loud happy little voice.
He said, I know what
they're doing, Mom!
I know what that is!
They're fucking, right, Mom?
Those tortoises are fucking!
So I tell that story as
a way of pointing out
that what was exciting
and interesting to my son
was different than what was
exciting and interesting to all
the other little kids.
So there's a little-- there
are two final endpoints
to that story.
My son is 22.
And he's about to start
his PhD in biology.
And so you know,
there's no direct link
between those things.
But it is true that his great
interest in the animal world,
in the natural world,
he already had it then.
It was easy to detect.
And it sustained
itself over time.
He's more curious than ever.
It's just that now his curiosity
is at an ever subtler, deeper
level.
The only other
funny thing I have
to tell because it
just happened is
that he recently came-- he goes
to school in another country.
And he recently came home
and brought his girlfriend
to visit in the Northeast.
And they went to
Central Park Zoo.
And he doesn't remember what
happened when he was four.
That's nothing to him.
And he came home from taking her
to the zoo, and he said, Mom.
There's the coolest
place at the zoo.
It's the tropical area.
And there are these
cool tortoises.
So obviously at some level
it had made a lasting impact
on him.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Alex.
I have two questions.
First one is current school is
the result of long evolution.
In general, is it needed
to speak something there?
Because now it is very formal.
It is set of obligations that
children should be fulfilled
without-- children who
don't have any curiosity
but-- like it covers curious
children and not curious,
but it works.
But what do you think is needed
to fix it and to improve.
It works well now.
And should be kept as is.
SUSAN ENGEL: I don't
agree with you.
I don't think our
current system does work.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Right.
SUSAN ENGEL: I think
that, first of all,
we have an incredibly
high illiteracy
rate in this country.
So there are many
children who can't read,
and most important, don't read.
So one of the
things I talk about
in "The End of the
Rainbow" is the difference
between measuring what a
child can do and what they do.
What we now call a disposition.
And that's much more valuable.
So we have kids who-- some
can't demonstrate competence.
But even many of those
who do don't actually
use those kinds of competence
in their everyday lives.
And I just saw
something in the news
this morning about how
few Americans actually
read about the records of people
they're going to vote for.
And since we have an election
coming up in a year and a half,
it seems very
relevant, people are
making very uninformed
decisions about who to vote for.
As one example, the
cheating in this country
is sky high at every level
in school and in business.
People cheat one another like
crazy, and cheat on their work.
And that has to do
with not having learned
how to take care of one
another or collaborate
when they're in school.
So I would say that
our current system--
while there are a lot-- I
need to make this clear.
There are many terrific
schools in this country,
and there are many terrific
individual teachers.
The ideas that I'm
suggesting would
build on those good
practices that are happening.
I just think that
they're happening
in spite of the current system,
instead of because of it.
I don't think our current
system is working.
And the fact that so many
people in their twenties
and thirties-- maybe not here at
Google, but across the country,
and even here in
your community--
are doing work that doesn't
feel meaningful to them,
and don't know how to find
other things in their life that
have meaning, pursuits, is to me
evidence that it's not working.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Google way,
the possible is it to develop
some application for instance,
for iPhone, that will measure
how many questions per hour
children ask in the school,
and give some [INAUDIBLE]
for parents like, your child
is very interested in math,
but not in language and so on.
How useful would it be?
SUSAN ENGEL: Well first
of all, I have to say I'm
an inveterate Googler.
And I think it's actually
really interesting.
People always ask me about
the dangers of technology
when they talk about school.
Is that going to
stop their curiosity?
We're just beginning
to gather evidence
on the impact of
technology on the way
that children think and learn.
But so far-- well,
it's complicated.
You must all know that.
It's complicated.
Being tied to your
phone or your iPad
can prevent certain
kinds of experiences,
social and sensual.
But it can allow for others.
For instance, getting
answers to your questions
is one of the most wonderful
ways to nurture curiosity.
I always liken it to being
hungry or wanting to have sex.
Those things only feel good
if you're going to have a meal
or you're about to
hook up with someone.
And the same is
true with curiosity.
It only feels good to
be curious if you're
gonna get some satisfaction,
some fulfillment,
for your curiosity.
And actually, technology is
a wonderful tool for that.
What you asked about is whether
you could turn an iPhone
into a measurer of that.
I think that would be
a great research tool.
And actually, I write about
this in the book about--
and there's some
really cool research
on tracking people's
habits online
to see what they-- you probably
all know about this better
than I do.
Do people sort of
look at many things?
Or do they delve deeper
and deeper into one thing?
There's a great term for that.
Research rapture.
You know, when
you start looking,
and then you gotta look at more.
And you can track that
online when people are
doing their searching online.
I think that's awesome.
I worry about this
idea that it's
going to be a new thing
that parents are going
to start measuring
like crazy and sort
of encouraging their children.
But you didn't ask
enough questions today.
Give me five more
before you go to sleep.
That seems horrible.
So that's not what
I have in mind.
And I don't have the answer
to how we-- you know,
I wrote a book called "Red
Flags or Red Herrings"
about parenting a few years ago.
And I found myself saying
to parents everywhere,
parenting is not a job that
you get A plus or D on.
It's a relationship.
And when I think
about parents who
are trying to make
these perfect children,
I link it all back to
this idea of money.
It has to do with some
obsession with getting your kid
to be the best.
Because if you weren't
trying to do that,
you would listen to
your child's questions
and answer them, and
ask your own questions.
And you wouldn't be
worried about whether they
had asked their quota of
questions for the day.
So that does worry me.
But as a tool for research
or for teachers to use,
I think it could be awesome.
AUDIENCE: And my second
question is more general.
SUSAN ENGEL: That was
only one question?
AUDIENCE: One plus.
Second question is about
overall or total education.
When we have it now, but there
is no da Vinci and no Newtons.
And da Vinci was in a
century where less than 1%
was educated.
But now here, as in Google,
we have many scientists
who know how to [INAUDIBLE].
Overall education, it
is achievement of it
is like, on the background
here now in the world.
SUSAN ENGEL: OK.
I didn't really understand
the end part of your question.
AUDIENCE: Like, with education,
like civilization-- achievement
of civilization.
Now almost will
people are educated.
But no Beethovens, no
Newtons, no Einsteins now.
SUSAN ENGEL: Who knows?
There may be some
lurking amongst us.
You know, there's
a great study that
was done 10 years ago by a guy
named Barron called the Teddy
Roosevelt Study, where he
took all these people that
accomplished great things.
And he looked for what they had
in common in their childhood.
And the only thing
that he could find
was all of them had spent
significant portions of time
out of school.
Because they had been too
far from school, or they
had been ill or whatever.
And I'm a school lover.
I love schools.
I've spent my
whole life in them.
So I value them deeply.
But I think it's
possible that actually we
haven't made schools places
where those qualities that
led to Roosevelt or da Vinci
or Newton could emerge.
And that relates
to my basic idea
that if schools
were to encourage--
I mean it's a great example.
Because most of the
people who've accomplished
great things had
really single-minded
focus on certain things, and
kind of lapsed at other things.
And there's nothing terrible,
nor need everybody be da Vinci.
But there would be
nothing terrible
in having a little more
of that in our schools.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I want go back to
the topic of this talk,
you know, money
versus happiness.
And by the way, I joined Google
just a couple of months ago.
So it's kind of really
whatever you pointed out
for children are actually
more applicable to me
right now than to children.
SUSAN ENGEL: Ah.
Good.
I think.
AUDIENCE: You know,
about the curiosity
versus measurables
and all of that.
But you know, when you compare
money against happiness,
it turns out happiness is
really difficult to pursue.
In many cases, money can
sometimes be easier to pursue.
Or at least you know when
you're making progress.
So as a parent, when I
look at my own experience--
and at Google, everybody
says, oh, be curious.
This is a different company.
It's not your normal company.
But the way they
let me in here is
through some pretty
rigorous testing.
And I worry about
that for my own kid,
especially now
that I'm at Google.
Oh, be Googly.
Have fun.
Do this.
Do that.
And you know, that's
not how I grew up.
You know, there were
standardized tests.
And I did well at them.
And you know, I'm at
a point in my life
where I can be as
Googly as I want.
But is that the right
thing to teach my child?
SUSAN ENGEL: Oh.
What a great question.
Well, first of all,
I don't know you.
So I don't know
all the qualities
that made you Googly-- a phrase
I never knew until just now.
But this is not everything.
So intelligence is
something important.
And it's something by and
large you're born with.
Though without
certain privileges
like stability and
health and basic needs
met when you're
little, you don't
get to fulfill your
intellectual capacity.
That's why we see
big class differences
in terms of the measure
of intelligence,
because if you have good
food and a same house
to go to every night
and conversations,
you will fulfill your
intellectual capacity more
than another kid.
But even so, some
people are going
to be smarter than others.
And maybe it's true that Google
hires the smartest people.
And that's going to
be true-- I mean,
maybe that's why you got hired.
And maybe that's
why you did well
on some of standardized tests.
So I'm not negating that.
But there are also
many people who are not
going to work at Google.
And it may be wonderful here.
I may be incredible
to be Googly.
But it's not the
only place to work,
and it's not the
only way to be happy.
It would be very
cool-- maybe you've
done it-- to do some measures
of whether people who work here
are happier in their lives.
That part's going to get
cut out of the video.
REGINA: I smile because
we look at [INAUDIBLE].
SUSAN ENGEL: Good.
I'd love to know more about it.
And you know, when I
use the word "happy"--
and I take great pains in
the book to talk about this--
I'm not talking
about having fun.
So I tell a story in
the book about when
my children were little and a
little kid came over to play.
And his mother went home
and told his mother,
let's play Susan and Jake.
That was my eldest boy.
And she said, how do
you play Susan and Jake?
And he said, you be Susan.
And you keep saying,
want a lollipop?
And that's not what I have
in mind for happiness.
I mean finding fulfillment,
finding meaning,
working with others.
Like I said, seeking
knowledge, being
able to be thoughtful
about things.
I think actually if schools
were to seriously focus
on those things, not
just pay lip service,
I don't know what Googly means.
Now I want to know.
But if it's just a
phrase, it's not much.
If it captures something
serious about the way
people do things here, well
I'm thinking of something
similar in schools.
And I'm guessing that if kids
did those things in schools,
many more of them would
be well-equipped to work
environments like this.
Yeah.
REGINA: That's one more
here in the corner.
And then I think we're at time.
And I'm going to sneak one
more question in and go over.
AUDIENCE: OK.
First of all, I really
like what you're
talking about as the training
for happiness and curiosity
and things like that.
I've seen it in my own children.
We had to take some out of
school because the way they
were taught just wasn't--
we teach them from home.
And believe me, even if
I've encouraged them, hey,
I want you to go into something
so I can live off of you,
they're not.
They all seem to be going
art or social type of things.
SUSAN ENGEL: Good for them.
AUDIENCE: Looking for
things that are happy.
And I've also seen how
the curiosity or the love
of learning is just
[INAUDIBLE] out based
on a teacher, based
off of a textbook,
and a way it's taught.
So I see how that cripples them.
My current 16-year-old
loves history,
but hated social
studies last year,
because the book
was frankly awful.
But so I see this as
a positive direction.
This is what we really need.
But how do you do this
and keep the bureaucracy
and the administration
out of it?
Because I've seen a lot
of good educational ideas.
But then they go
to the government
and they put all this other
stuff in, and then by the time
it gets back to the schools,
it's just a huge mess.
And the teachers don't
have any control.
And this sounds
like the teachers'
got to have complete control.
And you've got to really train
the teachers up very well
in advance on how
to be doing this.
It's not just
something you say, OK.
We're going to now do it.
SUSAN ENGEL: No.
I think that's really true.
And I think Regina
asked before about
whether there are any
schools that are doing this.
I think we are not making
use of the great models that
are out there.
There are schools
that are doing this.
And it's not because
they're keeping
administrators out of it.
It's because they have
good administrators.
And we just need
to build on that.
The question about
government is way beyond
my area of expertise.
You know, I'm such an optimist.
So I'm thinking, oh,
just change their minds.
But ha!
So E. O. Wilson, who
is sort of famous,
the most famous
biologist, really, alive,
who really developed
the idea of biodiversity
and is a powerful
spokesperson for ecology
and for the environment.
I was once listening
to him speak.
And someone said-- and I
think he's near 90 now--
and they said, faced with all
the problems with the way we
treat the environment and all
the species that have died off,
and all the problems, how do you
have the courage and the umph
to go on promoting these
better practices on the Earth.
And he said, what
choice do I have?
What's the alternative?
And I feel that way
about education.
So it's been hard to change
the minds of administrators
or to make schools-- that's
a whole other talk about how
you create the
conditions in the school,
and good teachers can be good.
And I think there are
clear ways to do that.
I don't get discouraged
or I don't give up
because what choice do I have?
So it's just a matter
of sticking with it
until we make some progress.
And making use of the
really good models
that are already out there.
REGINA: I'm just
going to squeeze
in the whole-- I'm really
concerned about my kid getting
into a good school.
What about for that
question and concern?
SUSAN ENGEL: Oh, boy oh boy.
I have--
REGINA: Especially college.
SUSAN ENGEL: Yeah.
Whoops.
That's a loud one.
That's OK.
So I'm going to quote
another educator about this.
Because he said
something that I thought
was so beautifully put, that
I've got to borrow from him.
His name is Alfie Kohn.
And he has said to groups
of people, how much damage
are you willing to
do to your child
to make sure they get into
a school that only appears
to be a little bit better
than some other school?
And what I mean
by that-- and I'm
guessing it's particularly
relevant for this kind
of a population--
is that this idea
that there's only a few
really good schools is crazy.
There are a lot of
really good schools.
There are so many good,
bright young people with PhDs
and they're not all at
Stanford, believe it or not.
They're all over the country
at all kinds of universities
and colleges, including
community colleges and state
universities.
The most important
thing is that your child
wants to go to school and wants
to go for the right reasons.
And I teach at a very selective
college-- Williams College.
And I can tell you
that they all benefit
in the more conventional
ways from having that degree.
But the ones that really
benefit are the ones
that actually are there to be
educated, and take something
out of college more than
just the piece of paper.
And that's what parents
should be thinking about.
REGINA: Well, I'm going to end
there just for the recording
standpoint.
Susan's going to
be available after.
Thank you everyone
for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]